So with tokens in OAuth we can
now control authentication and
authorization for our API Endpoints.
But what happens when users
are using the endpoint too much?
If we have one data hog constantly
pinging the API, our other users might
experience drops in performance or may
not be able to access our API at all.
Or maybe our API isn't available for
free and users should be paying for
a certain amount of access
over a period of time.
With rate limiting, we can give
our server a bit more control over
the amounts of requests we will request
from a user over a certain time period.
In this next video,
I will make a rate limited inpoint
in a Flask web application.
This exercise uses some more
advanced topics in Python.
I've added some links in the instructor
notes that cover some of these topics
more in detail.